there was a news story that came out
recently about the treatment of seals
during their selection process yeah I
saw it they were getting sprayed with
tear gas whilst they were on the ground
and they were made to sing Happy
Birthday so that they couldn't hold
their breath while it was happening I
see all that but there's very few people
in this world who want to do a job like
that and it takes a different kind of
mindset how hard that training is I
don't expect anybody to understand it
that's why when I speak and you don't
understand me it's probably a good thing
because that probably means I'm in an
area of life that you're not in I think
it's the same kind of feeling that I get
when I heard about Elon Musk telling the
employees at Twitter we're going to ask
you to work harder than you've ever
worked in your life Twitter is now a
company where people can go if they want
to be in the top hard working
programmers and software developers on
the planet everybody was up in arms
we're going back to this old version of
capitalism what they didn't account for
is that there is a cohort of people for
whom that's their dream it's the same
with the seals if you're not the sort of
person that is built to go through
selection it's like speaking a different
language